había un fuerte dispositivo de seguridad
en los alrededores del aeropuerto de
Brasilia y cientos de Seguidores del
expresidente esperándole delante del
portón principal pero les decepcionó al
salir a escondidas del aeropuerto se fue
directamente a la sede del partido
liberal donde fue recibido es sin la
presencia de periodistas por su esposa
Michelle y por el presidente del partido
en un comunicado la formación especificó
que reembolsonaro no tiene ningún evento
en su agenda de hoy tampoco está
previsto que haga ningún discurso pero
la semana que viene él debe asumir la
función de presidente de honor del
partido liberal lo que deja Clara su
intención de hacer oposición al actual
gobierno de Luis Ignacio lulada Silva en
la agenda del expresidente para los
próximos días es secreta podría venirse
aquí en Río de Janeiro donde tiene su
residencia en bajada lo que cierto es
que aquí en Brasil bolsonaro es
investigado en con la invasión de las
sedes de los tres poderes el pasado 8 de
enero por sus seguidores más radicales
en las últimas semanas se agregó otra
investigación esta vez sobre joyas y
otros valiosos obsequios que la recibió
de Arabia Saudita cuando era presidente
y que no entregó al Estado brasileño al
dejar al poder como está previsto por la
ley ya que se tratan de regalos
oficiales Entonces no se trata de una
vuelta heroica al país como él le
hubiera gustado es su futuro judicial es
muy incierto pero revolucionaron con
todavía una sólida base de apoyo para
todo lo que puede para intentar
desestabilizar al actual gobierno de
Lula